Tasha is with us in Tennessee hi Tasha
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you it's such a blessing to talk
to you you too
what's up I have a question so I want to
be able to buy a house
good because where I'm at now is just
not the best neighborhood but it's cheap
so I'm there so I owe about $30,000 in
debt so I'm just trying to figure out
should I work towards saving money
towards the down payment so I can come
away from where I'm at now or do I start
with the baby steps I really I'm really
just looking for God in some direction I
just I don't know what to do understand
so what's your household income I make
about 55 a year what's the thirty
thousand and debt on I have student
loans that total to about fifteen
thousand I have a car that are only old
$3,500 on thank goodness I like doctor
bills and other little things like that
that amount to ten thousand dollars um
I'm kind of really just guessing I'm
kind of eyeballing I'm not for sure okay
well the first thing we do first thing
you know there's do a very detailed list
of your guests and lets them smallest to
largest now in thirty years of doing
financial coaching with people I have
found zero people that regret being
debt-free and having their emergency
fund in place plus their down payment
before they buy I have found a lot of
people that bought a home while still in
debt barely got in there then the
stinking hot water heater goes out of
the roof leaks septic tank stops up
whatever and they're broke
the problem with homeownership is it is
a wonderful blessing over the long haul
as long as you have the money but when
you're broke there
thousand dollars in debt and you buy a
house it ends up being more of a curse
than a blessing I want you to get a
house I just don't want your house to
get you so if I were in your shoes what
I would do is make a detailed list of
those debts and I would say this is my
new game I'm gonna knock these puppies
out as fast as I can list them smallest
to largest attack get your every dollar
budget going attack with a vengeance on
that smallest debt when it's gone attack
the next one down when it's gonna attack
the next one down and every time you do
that you don't have that payment anymore
on that other one so it gives you more
money to attack right that snowball
rolls over picks up more snow and kind
of lay that out and look at that math a
little bit and see how long you think
you've got to be there if you're feeling
unsafe in the area that you're in you
may need to move and rent something in a
different neighborhood while you're
getting out of debt because it may take
you a year and a half or two years to
get out of debt and build that emergency
fund and build that downpayment my guess
is it probably will but I didn't hear
$30,000 in debt I heard eighteen five so
far fifteen and thirty five hundred
silly - you got it all in yeah
so 18 five I'm sorry all the hours -
probably like a $5,000 oh that's a big
one okay yes and you fix the problem
that caused that yes I fixed it okay
good
are you getting a big tax refund now
they can't be all right and you've got
them on payments other than that yes I'm
going to set them up on a payment plan
I'm just trying to figure out how to
budget in and live and paid it like I'm
really confused on how to do it all yeah
it gets complicated well all our budget
is is we're gonna list our put our
income for the week or two weeks or
month at the top of the page and then I
want to give every one of those dollars
an assignment down the page I'm going to
buy food with it I'm gonna buy lights
and water with it I'm going to pay my
rent I'm gonna pay the single
regular payments on these bills and then
when I find money that's left over I'm
gonna use it to attack this debt and no
luxuries in this budget because we're
trying to get out of debt so we can get
a house and every time we go out to eat
again it keeps us from getting out of
debt to get a house anytime we do
anything go on vacation that keep that
car that money if it had gone towards
the debt you got a house faster so we
got it you got to make it a big priority
and that's all you are doing is focusing
on that hold on we are running a 14-day
free trial on Financial Peace University
I'll put you on hold and Kelly will pick
up and let you know how to sign up for
that and you can get that 14-day free
trial going and at Dave Ramsey dot-com
slash hope and that'll help you get it
going and you can get in there and learn
about this stuff a little bit and then
you'll want to stay in financial peace
you know through this time for certain
and learn how to not only get out of
debt but be able to get in the position
to buy that house